welcome to occasionally awesome Nick
Yusuf I'm Kevin Christy I slow to talent
down that yeah i'm perfect i'm gonna be
every time I was gonna see if you were
no yeah my leaf litter welcome to okay
I'm hit 97 like the road okay well we're
here yep it is January 12th the Tuesday
I hope your new year's going well we'll
make the intro short quick as I don't
really have much to promote but that's
not me this is that who is a I don't
know that me it must be it's not me
where's that coming from
let my phone it just decided to start
playing David Bowie that was [ __ ]
weird must have told your wife I to do
it or something I opened my calendar and
it was all uh this is necessary now are
you listening to it in your car I was
listening to earlier but yeah but it was
like not even it was not playing and I
didn't pull up the Apple music thing
whoa look guys um Wow so real quick
before the spirit of a legend takes over
my phone again yes um wilmington north
carolina i'm going to be playing
headlining the dead crow comedy club
29th and 30th of january so if you live
in north carolina come to that and then
the following week february's second
through seventh so many days las vegas
the improv at Harrah's all week it's
gonna feel like a decade if you live out
there come to the shows or tell me what
and where to go eat and do things
because I'm basically going to be moving
they're frickin awake and then oh I'm
sorry I her vine I'm playing the irvine
improv january 21st through 23rd and
februari 18 through the 21st the chicago
improv all that stuff will be on my
website Nikki usf calm gigs come to
those shows Chicago North Carolina Vegas
and more to be added and more to be
announced on this podcast and on my
website and what do you got don't anyone
be at the store up yeah and then
yeah Neil show every Sunday Neal Brennan
friends Westside comedy theater great
night of comedy that show and very good
lately yeah I'm sure it's always good I
mean audience was just audience why I've
been always been like super full lately
ah the workshop show is still gonna go
on by the way you guys some of you have
come to that there's gonna be I'm still
working on the January date so there's
going to be one man februari and March
what's one Wednesday a month it's a new
material night I host at the comedy
store with just awesome comments it's
not going to be like a Comedy Store
lineup I don't want it to be like that
so it'll be you know you'll see one or
two guys from there and then just like
really funny cool comics from around
town that should be at the comedy store
and will be because they're going to be
on the show so those line-ups will be
i'll announce in here and and website
and twitter and all that so that's a
good show Rogan does it a lot it's and
everyone's doing new stuff so even if
you see a lot of comedy you'll see all
these guys do it brand new [ __ ] so I
think that's I know I'm forgetting
something but we're gonna have a new
t-shirt soon oh that's right what's
going on with us this week I'm finally
not sick I had to go to an actual doctor
yeah I had to go to urgent care urgent
care but not nerdy care clinic not the
emergency room oh yeah what happened i
had a like an actual like [ __ ]
respiratory infection was so lame it
wouldn't go away normally you get a cold
three four days you lay in bed take a
bunch of dayquil nyquil one away just
would not go away I had to go get actual
antibiotics what the [ __ ] what happened
is that a thing that's going around I
guess yeah they said they're just like
there's a is it contagious well I think
at one point it was but usually
contagion who do you think you got it
from I got it from Dean he was the only
sick person i was at been around lately
and he got sick in San Francisco you
shared a mic I pretty sure I got it from
him
and then yeah but it wouldn't go away it
was weird and annoying wow just coughing
up things that look like brain matter
wow lame so I went to a doctor got some
matches that sucks dude but then you're
fine now you're selling the medicine or
ya soon a mess but i can finally like be
a person do stuff Wow yeah well yeah we
have the design and I'm gonna go meet
with the printers this week hopefully
and then it's I feel like it once i do
that it'll be less than a couple weeks
away [ __ ] yeah yeah so there you have it
guys new will tweak the design soon
people can see it new shirt I've seen
the design and it's [ __ ] awesome it
is rad town USA that's where it's from
yeah haha origin of design rat town USA
destination worldwide that's where it's
going one of the dumbest things you have
yep that used to be my location on my
rad town on my Twitter it's like city
which is adjusted rat and then I change
to [ __ ] USA I like when people do uh
sent from iphone jokes or put funny
things in their locations on Instagram
yeah I appreciate that when it's like
always chilies reflect off boys always
stuff like that i'm a big fan always
like dominos pizza and glendale that's
good yeah it's a fun little yeah one-off
thing yeah my signature my email used to
be sent from my iphone while texting and
driving yeah good yeah and then you just
do it once and forget it's there yep um
so sunday night i went to church you did
I went to church you recharge your
simple i recharge my spiritual batteries
it's these are important things to do
they really are yeah and and i realized
that after the show ended uh in more
ways than one but for the layman by the
way a church means i went to see to live
in concert yeah I didn't go to Mass I
didn't go worship God I went worship the
gods of music a progressive alt metal
band tool yeah buddy if right now you're
thinking oh that's the band that did
that song sober and then that was it no
okay they turned in
geniuses after that so if your if your
musical knowledge of them stops then now
it's like if you stop listening to
radiohead at pablo honey yeah that's
true or what was the whatever the one
after that [ __ ] car please no no well no
Pablo Honey was the one with [ __ ] I'm
forgetting my Radiohead this is like
sacrilege right now yeah my mind's been
on another [ __ ] yeah it why can't think
of any I can never this is why I never
[ __ ] bends yeah this is Christ so
that's if you stop eliciting I'm
literally thing of all the songs on it
fake plastic trees no so that's like if
you stop listening to radiohead at the
bend yeah then you would never know ok
computer what they went to outer space
cool same thing after undertow they
release anema and you're like oh these
guys went to jupiter and met with aliens
mm-hmm and then they were like here's
how to make music so yeah so I went and
saw them and it was like always an
amazing sonic visual [ __ ] soul
[ __ ] do they have good projection
stuff in the background and [ __ ] oh yeah
there I mean their whole show they have
lights but is there is there like a
screen behind them with stuff on it yeah
there's multiple there's the one
directly behind them to over on the side
and they have one like below that like
uh that runs the perimeter of the drum
ok stage with the drummer's on nah and
it's just stuff going on this lasers and
like it's a very visual they make it
about that and not like just light
shining on the band members and watch
them do [ __ ] yeah um because I their
songs are a kind of difficult to play
that I imagine it doesn't lend itself to
the musicians like running around and
doing stuff yeah yeah train yeah they
don't really ever do that I mean they
let the you know the the light show and
the video kind of speak for and do that
for them so it's very like it's so well
orchestrated in timed and but they're
great they played some older stuff they
haven't played in a while and they
reworked some of it so it was like cool
live versions of their songs uh it was
[ __ ] awesome that's my 14th times
good yeah good um and word is that
they're kind of halfway through or more
work on their new album right um now
that all their legal issues and all that
stuff is behind them they're like
they're chugging away so hopefully I
think before the end of the year we'll
have something and then hopefully a
world tour or something where they
[ __ ] playa los angeles date quit
making me drive to other cities which i
will do even if they choose not to play
again um so but yeah after the show uh
we got in the car started heading back
to LA and then I got a text that just
said from a friend that just said David
Bowie yeah and then I responded yeah
he's great the best yeah and she because
I'm in this venue the only thing I'm
doing is taking out my phone to take up
to three pictures put him on Instagram
put the phone away yeah so and you don't
really have service anyway cuz everyones
online so i had no idea what that meant
and then I go yeah he's great send she
text back he just died yeah and then I
was like oh no I saw it on Twitter
because his his official Twitter tweeted
something and people thought it was a
hoax for about I'd say an hour to yeah
and then it what time was that it was
probably 1030 so that was like a half
hour before the show and because I ok
when I saw that I was like I didn't what
the when cuz ya earlier today or today I
was like I has an official Twitter
that's not like him doing it it's like
the official fan Twitter yeah post David
Bowie news and it said like he died
quietly and people thought it was a hoax
for a little while cuz you know someone
hacked into the again yeah and he
there'd been no mention of him having
cancer or anything at 18 month battle
with cancer had no [ __ ] clue it's
pretty cool for a guy to not mention the
end cancer it's pretty [ __ ] bad ass
but he uh yeah so a niche so I kept
searching and searching and searching
and searching there was a lot of people
like saying is it a hoax or not and then
it by the time I drove home and I didn't
look my phone when I was driving by the
time I got home it was on AP yeah and
then yeah and that it was like um dude
like I don't it's hard to eat it sits
like dumb he's one of those guys that it
sounds dumb to say like to do so who's
the best like I I can although i was
talking to okay i read this book
recently called punk elegies written by
a guy named Alan McDonald and he was uh
in la at the beginning of punk in LA and
I was talking about my was like when it
first started what was it like he goes
we got to realize that everyone at that
time was just trying to be Bowie that in
you know 77 78 is that you know he gets
called proto-punk right but just as far
as the that being cool and weird at the
same time Bowie's just the the guy yeah
he just was like I'm that when the first
time the first time he ever got on TV
was 17 and he like staged a fake kind of
publicity stunt of like about having
long like trying to fight for the rights
of men with long hair right and he just
kind of anyone like British television
and was like and was being very serious
about how men with long hair get like
verbally bullied in public yeah and was
like to pretending to be like no ed this
is that this is a serious cause we need
to fight he was like 17 is a performance
art this dude like I don't Bowie gets it
he go he got it in a way that I don't
know that anyone really did yeah I mean
it's hard to think of someone who kind
of did that before him um and then it's
easy to think of a lot of people that
did it after him as a direct result yet
of him there's like oh yeah we all got
how to be weird in glam and different in
and and push the boundaries of things
because Bowie did it but before told
Bowie is the thing just like who aliens
yeah like literally every time you like
there's a reason this do it it's like a
joke that David Bowie's an alien cuz
he's like if anyone's a space alien it's
it if it but David Bowie I think other
person space alien it's his wife Iman
right well you like a look space here
from David Bowie's been from the future
since the late sixties right I think
what it is is that I I think why it
strikes a chord with people like hits
home is that like he didn't like get it
I don't think he got that from
anywhere i think it was like this thing
that like exists in people the the the
the want or the desire to like express
themselves in a way that's outside of
the norm are kind of unusual right but
most of us go yeah that that's too weird
or I'll get a lot of flak or people make
fun of me or they'll think things that
mean they'll think I'm you know gay or
weird or yeah that uh you know a
multitude of things so you end up just
going like I'll just wear that these
regular colors I'll just wear pants that
fit this way I'll wear this shirt in
this half but he I think the only real
difference and not to take away from how
unique or anything he was but I think
the only real difference is he had all
those like thoughts and feelings that a
lot of us do and he just said I'm gonna
do it and not care it's almost like he
was so busy being it he he was too busy
being it to think about yeah what people
would think of him being it yeah you're
just there that filter or that like
self-consciousness that that insecurity
thing just wasn't there wasn't strong
enough to prevent him so he just said
I'm gonna wear a [ __ ] skin tight silk
onesie dress then whatever the hell and
then like giant platform yeah knee high
heel yes well I mean I know I
immediately like I was driving home and
I was thinking about I was like man this
you know and I got home I thought and I
saw that he was dead house sucks i did
still drawing yeah impulses Lynette is a
puzzle drawing if I did lightning bolt a
little I or whatever and I start looking
at Instagram and the thing is now if you
look at internet in last two days you
see it's like sixty percent pictures of
David away right now but I realized
before that I look at Instagram all the
time and I look at the Explorer function
all the time yeah it's still before he
died it was ten percent David Bowie yeah
i mean the the the people doing spins on
the ziggy stardust lightning bolt face
paint is i can't tell you how prevalent
it is yeah in things I see in skate
design in tattoo stuff and just art in
general it's like him dying only
up his is like presents visually buy
like fifty percent yeah it's still there
it's kind of everywhere I mean that's
like he is a he's a pop culture icon and
yeah in more ways than just music in
like you know I mean a little bit in the
acting world but like uh music and style
yeah he just like permeates the country
in the world and in a lot of ways that
you don't even really notice yeah but
when you sit there and go let's trace
back where that came from it goes back
to like this you know 60 70 s when like
people were just becoming free or
spirits and going up an address and act
however the [ __ ] I want yeah I'll blur
and blur the gender lines but he took it
to another level the the the real I mean
when you think about the gent his his
mark when it comes to blurring the
gender lines is [ __ ] massive yeah so
early on that it wasn't you didn't even
realize what he was doing until 20 30
years later yeah there's a reason that
like were where we are now he's one of
the reasons like he started it then yet
when you look at comedy and go why are
we allowed to say and do what we want
it's because of like guys like Lenny
Bruce but they did it so long ago the
impact doesn't really settle in yet
later on yeah it takes the it takes like
a nation or or or culture a while to
like absorb whatever change has happened
yet happens in 1963 it's not until 10 15
20 years later where everyone's
comfortable doing it yeah you know Bowie
starts dressing like that not everyone
in a high school in suburban America's
wearing that kind of Shem and dyeing
their hair orange no it's 10 or 15 years
later when you're like I was like eight
ten percent of people do this it'll take
a risk and yeah I'll put on some weird
fish net yet hand arm things yeah you
know now he's the he's the guy who like
was like I'll take the [ __ ] a lot in a
lot of ways and I think aunt again I'm
not a music historian I'm probably a
little off base here right but he as far
as like setting the tone for the
constant recreation of like this is my
new persona
yeah and doing that repetitively of like
know every album is going to be markedly
it is gonna be noticeably different yeah
I'm going to change constantly that's
advantage it's a huge risk yeah huge
thing that like Neil Young did that yeah
where he would just release an album and
it would be a critical and you know
financial success and then he would go I
don't want to do that again and people
would say are you insane yeah that's all
your success all the money's gone and
that was secondary to guys like him
David Bowie and they just were like it's
about the art and the expression and the
creativity and moving forward yeah and
you gotta think so many people around
more like this guy's an idiot this is
insane I mean he tried I mean he got a
lot of trouble when he did he kind of
dress like a fascist for a minute yeah
got busted at customs with some Nazi
memorabilia yeah and he was just doing
this stuff he see the art came so first
in the process of it that the
repercussions he was kind of like well
we'll see what happens yeah and I think
that to me is what's so [ __ ] bad ass
about the guy I know he's so incredibly
badass I mean I told you there's this
clip by someone tweeted a clip of its
david bowie and he's on mtv in its 1983
which it means mtv hasn't been on for
very long at all it's not like two years
yeah and he's basically let he's he's
arguing with this with this vijay i
forget the guy's name is the guy with
the kind of italian looking guy with big
curly hair and David Bowie's going no no
i I've been watching and it's
interesting what you guys are doing so
far I like it why are there so few black
artists on your channel right now yeah
and it's not like it was like oh guys
like will I know for what we want to do
and he's like no no but like there's
very few and I've noticed they're only
on between two and three a.m. and then
Bowie just like sits earns like what so
why is that happening yeah waiting for
like he's gonna like he's considering
investing or whatever you know and it's
just like this dude this dude had it so
right and you just like where did what
it's so interesting when people are like
that when someone for some reason
they're just busy
our alchemy of theirs so far ahead of
the game mentally yeah where everyone
else is kind of like the school's pedals
I mean it's just they'll say the things
that you're not as like a a star
celebrities kind of supposed to say well
celebrity to be worried that they're on
TV and that the guy sitting across them
is going to make them look bad boys like
no man why is that seems sort of dumb
and racist you guys gonna fix it yeah in
the vijay's like but I mean marketing
and Bill of a market to have a bar this
thing you're like what what do you say
it as most people would be in the chair
going like all right now to like make
myself look good now have this like
forum on MTV I'm gonna like make myself
look awesome so I gotta think of all the
right things to say in a dress and act
and like it should answer all the
questions and smile a guy like him is
just like oh I noticed this injustice so
I'm we're going to talk about that yes
and it doesn't matter what the outcome
is yeah you know but it's also way
braver for someone who's popular to do
that I noticed there's there's people
who get who get like political either
when there's they have nothing to lose
right or they're so far past it that
they can't you can't hurt them you can't
hurt them anymore but like that he
wasn't he hadn't been big for that long
in comparison to how long he was going
to be big right he could certainly have
pissed people often was the early
incarnation of MTV they could have been
like let's not show David Bowie videos
yeah we have that guy back on he
understood his power enough to raise
like well if you're gonna if I'm gonna
spend my if I'm gonna use some of my
record label budget to make music videos
to provide content for your channel I
want to talk about some stuff yeah you
know he's a big he had a real I'm sure
you had a real sense of like music
history in the people of matters like
there's actually a lot of people of
color doing interesting [ __ ] is he not
be putting him on your network why is
that yeah give it a 24-hour channel
what's the problem that was like the end
of his like uh soul phase to him like
that philly soul thing that yeah he's
doing which made some great albums but
he is a deep into that so he was
probably extra aware yeah you know is
like we're all [ __ ] black people who
make real music I mean I by today I talk
I was talking about this last night with
Niels
watch the Golden Globes and like you
know the the presenting parts are lame
and they're usually ham-fisted in but
like Kevin Hart did a really good job
and he just like was really professional
energetic you're like Kevin Hart had to
be so good just to get normal famous
right that it's just proof that it like
there's certain people in show business
we're like there's their proof that
Hollywood still racist because they're
so super good they're like yet Kevin
Hart's so [ __ ] funny and he had to
become he had to feel like stadiums for
someone to be like that's given me a
normal comedy that will give some
garbage white person yeah give four of
those to a garbage person yeah exactly
like a just a boring ass actor who's
like okay or funny ish yeah like Kevin
Hart's straight up funny a hundred
percent of the time yeah and and but
like use in in / and be like perfect
like no mistakes really like some movies
maybe didn't love but he's like keeps it
like day delivers yeah balilla delat
will ferrell do a movie in Spanish not
that will ferrell's not hilarious but
they let him do a movie in Spanish right
that made eleven dollars I saw it in the
theater was horrific so you're the guy
who paid yeah I was like this is weird
nose like got and I left Matt I was like
goddamn it right yeah a David Bowie
quote I don't know where I'm going from
here but I promise it won't be boring
this guy yeah who can say that and then
follow through but we could say he could
get away with so much weird [ __ ] I know
also dude was cut he was kind of
hilarious yeah he's funny there's a he
was on he was really funny on extras oh
that's right Zoolander yeah I mean he
his first big hit was you know Space
Oddity right ground control to Major Tom
which that's like Spacey and weird and
like cocktail are you what do you hit a
real obsession with the with the outer
space yeah then I mean I think the net
the man who sold the world right [ __ ]
epic song I first discovered that song
watching Nirvana's unplugged yeah I was
like what the [ __ ] nirvana song is this
this is amazing and they were like oh
that's the David and you didn't even
find that out like that week or that
month
there's no googling you just had
different someone had to know about it
yeah they told you oh my older brother
listen to Bowie and he said those above
all cool then you know the problem with
like our age group in anyone younger is
we heard a lot of this [ __ ] out of order
yeah you hear a lot of luckier changes a
lot oranges are young Americans on the
radio so you get tired of a lot of like
Bowie songs Regina girl yeah Beatles and
and in all these like different artists
at that they just hammer you would like
their big hits yeah so when you hear
certain songs just like how this again
but then when you get into the album's
listen to the album's you're like oh wow
yeah like there's like some real [ __ ]
that's why they're playing the single
because this guy just like made amazing
music like beginning and like a rebel
rebel is a good song you hear it a lot
and it doesn't really do much for you
but that entire album that it's on
Diamond Dogs is so great I [ __ ] love
when David Bowie makes a stripped-down
rock song yeah it is a goddamn banger
yeah I mean rebel rebel is so good I
know but I think I probably first heard
changes or that you know that the
Christmas song with Bing Crosby lead to
a little drummer boy on up have you
heard it oh dude it's [ __ ] beautiful
man yeah and Bowie and David Crosby look
punk is [ __ ] right you're like it first
of all whose idea was it I'm thinking
it's david bowie's right and then they
sing little drummer boy it's beautiful
and you're like Bing Crosby's kind of
cool [ __ ] right now single boy um but
yeah sounds like changes and the big
ones dancing in the street with Mick
Jagger I probably saw that on MTV like
10 million times all right when he did
uh under pressure that was great was
with Freddie Mercury ah that was pretty
awesome the first few times I heard that
on the radio I was just like where has
this song been my entire life why am I
just now and that's what I like he's a
guy that like it you get the sense that
he wanted to just be in a band but like
he kind of it you know it toured with
with Iggy yeah and he anonymously played
the drum
as I think yeah and they went on tour he
toured with him too and played piano
it's [ __ ] crazy is just like I'm just
gonna do cool [ __ ] with cool artist yet
they sit there there was I was watching
me as a behind the music and he's like
yeah we we decided we both needed to
kick heroin so I went on tour with them
we were trying to kick hair when we went
to Berlin the heroin capital of the
world right he's like and then I quit
the tour cuz we had some fight like i
don't like your pants news like i don't
like your hair we broke up that's where
he got sober though yeah they managed to
do it in in berlin yeah he made all
those like weird [ __ ] uh techno ish
records with with you know yet but the
he got the sense that he wanted to be in
a band he's talking about it in in the
we in Ziggy Stardust that like the Dino
he got too big for the band and he's
standing out that like he seemed to be a
guy that wanted to be around musicians
and and like you know that kind of
collaborative what do we do let's make
it weird let's push it kind of thing but
he was just he was so David Bowie that
people are like no no you're like the
best you have to be this massive star I
think maybe that's why he changed so
much so he could like okay what can I be
that's different now and then I can
that'll give me an excuse to like formed
Tin Machine or whatever and then I can
be surrounded I could do like this new
thing and like work with this different
person and whatever that he seemed to be
a guy that was just obsessed with music
like obsessed he just like cared about
like the making of it like any wanted to
like this it's so hard to find bands
that continuously push the envelope and
she like reinvent themselves without a
care of like it ruining their you know
career like their perceived image yeah
um normally you get a band that like is
derivative like a lot of bands are when
they start that you can you can't really
hear and see their influences and then
like they figure out something that
clicks and then they just kind of copy
that album that they've gotten big two
or three times until they fade into
obscurity and then you sort of forget
about it but the band's stick around are
the ones that keep changing and during
that change you get annoyed or
they lose some fans you go what the [ __ ]
are they doing yeah but like you know
the artists life is like long the
careers long if you're in it for that so
like when you step back and look at the
trajectory and what they're doing you go
oh I see like what when you're like kind
of tunnel vision on it when you're
looking at song per song or album
problem you don't really get what's
going on and you're kind of annoyed you
can't stick with it because it's
familiar and you liked it so you kind of
want more the same but yeah if you kind
of let them do their thing and like just
kind of try and follow where they're
going and they're if they're good
they're very talented like you know
you're a Bowie or a prince or Neil Young
or whatever they'll they'll take you
there you just gotta like trust that
they'll do it Bowie's one of the dudes
that like invented that as a thing yeah
it was most a lot of artists just were
like nup here's the other song that
sounds like the other song that you
liked yeah cuz you know I think it's so
hard to get big as a musician you kind
of understand why they're like to cook
we need a hit yeah and he like as i was
reading through a lot of these you know
his discography and stuff it'd be like
this one peaked at number five in the UK
it's like he wasn't making number one
hits like all the time that was sort of
weird it was and that's I mean people
later on look back and go oh these were
conceptual albums that now stand the
test of time and are awesome and you see
their info what their influence did you
get you've gotten used to that kind of
music yeah you know you see what it's
done and then you look back and go oh I
get it now cuz then your does it this is
new and weird like the first when punk
first came out I always noise rock
you're just like this is noise yeah and
then it kind of starts to make sense
later on to some people you know the
music savvy people they kind of get it
right away they go this is the next
thing this is new yeah I'm on the ground
floor I know what's going on but your
average person at first is like I don't
get it in the same way like you know
stylish stuff like kind of starts in
certain areas of the country and you see
people wearing I go what the [ __ ] why is
that guy wearing boots like that or
jackets like that yeah and then three
years later they're in urban outfitters
and everyone has it on yeah and they go
no yeah it's cool bro you're like three
years ago you're [ __ ] calling that
guy queer you know
like the the elastic band of pants with
the like the elastic on the bottom neck
now like three years ago they just look
like a fitted yet dumb Kanye pants but
now I see them on everybody everybody
yeah to where I was like I'm too old to
get that but my in my head I'm like do I
need to get those pants right yeah I
will get him as fitted sweats yeah but I
won't get him as like fitted jeans or
anything like that I just think that
looks slowly put out 27 studio records
on a tour but like a lot once it's
interesting when someone's been around
that long in your head you're like
there's probably like ten albums 15
hours like nope there's like tons and
tons and tons of material yeah I mean he
was putting albums out to for a while
like one a year yeah but back then
though like bit you know you're putting
albums out on on the LP format so
they're not like it wasn't like the late
eighties into the nineties where albums
were like 78 minutes long or whatever
like they're under an hour yeah you know
which is not to take away from you know
anything really but because a lot of
like they're all when you listen to like
old comedy albums like there were comics
that put albums out like a like once a
year or whatever sometimes more what I
look how the [ __ ] but they were like 40
minutes longer 3743 so but I mean to be
really good is another thing because
there are a lot of bands and artists
that put out album after album you have
certain bands you barely heard they have
like nine studio albums which is not
that common yes four studio albums to be
but like the label had to go we want you
to put out a ninth album and it's like
no one really knew but but yeah 26 is a
lot and to stay like respected and
relevant all the way through that I mean
they were like obviously downs and ups
and stuff but I mean look at the way it
is now the guys dead and no one is
anything but like I've never I can't
think of anyone ever making fun of David
Bowie yeah I don't yeah he was never
like a cultural joke at any point no cuz
he never like he got out of the drug
thing early on before it became like you
know yikes uh like he wrote through that
it was a little weird
but he was already weird so you never
knew what yeah is he high is that but he
cleaned up and got a [ __ ] together and
just you know kept going and then he for
someone that took that many risks he
really did a good job of like managing
managing it you know and never got away
from him yeah because people were just
almost like what is gonna happen next
yeah you know and then whatever it was
was interesting and good and like
thoughtful it wasn't like what you know
your lady gaga's and people like that
are doing which is just generally like a
copy of a copy of a copy right and they
don't really have a lot of it doesn't
seem like a lot of control over and it's
like a manufactured thing but it doesn't
really come from like within no they
they're not taking in a direction
they're sitting there in meeting rooms
going like where are we going without
any real you know like vision for for
the future because like a a guy like him
it just was like it k really came from
like within i need to express myself in
this way not like let's crunch the
numbers and i feel like he was the one
being like I want to make it out with
this guy or I'm gonna go find it's gonna
be like this it came from his own
personal interest which is why it seems
so some of it seems so weird as it
wasn't that didn't seem like marketing
based at all he got a lot of [ __ ] for
that though career-wise like people
would like critics and stuff would would
say he's just like jumping on trends and
styles and then reinventing himself in
that way and like I mean I wouldn't
argue too much against that but like he
still did it so well yeah and I don't
mind I don't mind someone great spin on
something right like Madonna reinvented
herself and she got [ __ ] for that you
should wall now she's an eighties person
now she's this but she's so talented and
so good you're it's part of the
evolution you know if you're gonna grow
and you're like and you're an artist of
whatever kind and you're speaking about
your personal life or a reflection of
what's going on in society you're
obviously going to change with the
society like you can't look like you're
from the 60s in 1987 then you're then
the criticism is they're out of date
yeah so like and that's the prob
with critics is that they're always
finding something wrong with their job
exactly yeah so they say that kind of
stuff about Bowie and and Madonna and
whoever else but it's like well what
what's the alternative yeah don't ever
change then you're gonna criticize how
they don't ever change one of my
favorite David Bowie songs is a probably
as one of those times where he heard
music going in two directions like I
like this I want to make a song like
this so i'm gonna call Trent Reznor I'm
gonna make I'm afraid of Americans yeah
and that sounds like a nine inch nails
song like a a a more a poppier nine inch
nails song with David Bowie and I
[ __ ] love that song yeah it's cool
it's fun for a movie I don't know it was
for a movie okay yeah they did it for uh
let me google it songs good as [ __ ] dude
I remember the video it's [ __ ] good
and you're like he was probably like oh
you know what I this nine inch nails
things kind of interesting its
industrial south it reminds me of what I
was doing in the 70s but it's harder I'm
gonna call him and you know reznor's at
his home like David Bowie's on the phone
you're like hey David Bowie like it's
[ __ ] cool it was uh originally
appeared as a rough mix on the
soundtrack to show girls but a lot ah
out of all things yeah well something
good came out of that film ina [ __ ]
movie that's that that that song is so
good yeah I remember the video I was
just like what is happening you're like
lots of black eye makeup on you had a
shiny black jacket yeah that was good
anyway you know he's wearing a [ __ ]
turtleneck yeah yeah David Bowie ahead
of the curve David Bowie stayed wearing
a turtleneck I'll get a [ __ ]
tournament right now he could I mean if
you want to talk dudes who could wear
whatever they wanted he is that dude he
could wear it like a w knows mock
turtlenecks dark and a half ago he
coulda got double and it's like that
thing's covering half his mouth I see
David Bowie walk down the street a Von
Dutch t-shirt my bio Von Dutch I bye-bye
company stock stocks in the company well
you actually could was its was it you
could buy stock and David Bowie what it
was either him or sting look it up at
one point you
by david bowie futures David Bowie stock
Bowie's stock it was him or sting dude
that I remember this I don't think it
worked uh it with him he he launched the
first bond back by back catalog yeah the
body but also you bought stock in his in
his hat in the future profits of his
back catalogue I thought it was like and
him as a human why not it kind of is
because if he would have gotten super
lame he would have liked you know his
back at 97 yeah it was 55 million by
promising investors income generated by
his back catalogue of 85 albums sold his
rights to future royalties for music
recorded before 1992 a group of
investors who then issued a 10-year bond
the man behind the Bowie bond was banker
david pullman to claimed it was the
first time a musician it sold
intellectual property rights via a bond
and then he created similar deals for
James Brown Ashford and Simpson and
Marvin Gaye the concept even spawned a
novel I I would be curious to see what
that bond ended up being worth while the
arrangement may have been lucrative for
Bowie it does not appear to have paid
off for investors it was literally the
next sentence right he's the best which
I'm sure he knew some guy was like you
want 50 million dollars for your back
catalogue and he was like 'hey wow yeah
oh you know what did it was the online
music thing oh yeah that makes total if
that hadn't happened the investors would
have made money you know what's
interesting is in 1996 david bowie
released a record on the internet so you
obviously saw the online music thing
coming and was like you know what i
should probably do get a lot of money
for the [ __ ] i'm not gonna be a lot get
a lot of money for later there is a the
quote i was trying to look for i read it
i think yesterday it's a like two
paragraphs but it's it's very likely i
mean the foresight he goes this was two
thousand one or two or something like
that I don't even know why I would want
to be on a label in a few years because
I don't think it's going to work by
labels and by distribution systems in
the same way the absolute transformation
of everything that we ever thought about
music will take place within ten years
and nothing is going to be able to stop
it I see no point in pretending that
it's not going to happen I'm fully
confident the copyright for instance
will no longer exist in ten years and
authorship and intellectual property is
in for such a bashing music itself is
going to become like running water or
electricity so it's like just take
advantage of these last few years
because none of this is ever going to
happen again you'd better be prepared
for doing a lot of touring because
that's exactly the only unique situation
that's going to be left it's terribly
exciting but on the other hand it
doesn't matter if you think it's
exciting or not it's what's going to
happen and that's literally what's
happening yet the copyright thing not
yet but I mean that you music will be
like running water electricity and you
better start touring cuz that's how
you're gonna make money he's right about
the copyright thing because it it's it's
not gonna get it is it has gotten a
beating cuz having the copyright to your
own publishing because of Spotify is
close to worthless you know he said I'm
fully confident the copyright will no
longer exist in ten you know you mean uh
intellectual property isn't for such a
bashing and it is that part is true
because it's like you're not [ __ ]
makin ya making [ __ ] off [ __ ] anymore
but and then next paragraph you better
start touring because that's the only
thing that's gonna do it and that is
exactly the state of the music industry
right now but like guys like him [ __ ]
early on were like this is where it's
headed and you'd be stupid to deny it
you just go with it you cannot stop the
change that's coming yeah and it's a
little easier for guys I came to say who
are sitting on a mountain of money and
they've already made all there but I
mean those guys were right yeah but we
was right man yeah one of my favorite
things he did later on and I tweeted a
link to it was like he was into and a
lot of older artists don't do this they
like they're like oh I get all my music
info for my kids or whoever like they
don't know a lot of what's going on with
the younger generation because they're
just listening to world music or weird
[ __ ] or like nothing I'm serious a lot
of older artists listed like weird to go
I'm really into like experimental Latin
jazz from Chile you know like they
listen to that stuff because like
they've listened to so much
music and a lot of them are real
musicians so that's what's interesting
you know so they're not listening to
like the [ __ ] radio were like you
know what like current pop rock acts are
doing you know but he would be like he
was early on early proponent of the
arcade fire mm-hmm he was just like
these guys are great they're gonna be
big and like that and he did it with TV
on the radio like press from David bow
if David Bowie comes out and goes I'm a
really big fan of this band I think
they're great Rolling Stone and
pitchfork its but all these guys are
like okay let's you know let's figure
out what they're about let's see how
good they are and then he would like go
on tour with them and [ __ ] like the the
link i tweeted was him singing wake up
with the arcade fire yeah on stage like
a guy in his 50s or 60s like he doesn't
need to be doing that also like being in
arcade fire and just being like did you
guys remember when David Bowie came on
tour with us yeah remember when he was
like can I sing a song with you in
concert like shits crazy man that for
any band if your band ended the next
week would you'd be like yeah I'm good
with that I'm good written david bowie
endorsed us and then sang with us and
it's not like he doesn't know what he's
doing right knows he knows is like he
knows what he is he knows he's David
[ __ ] Bowie it created himself his real
name wasn't David Bowie yeah he gets it
he's like I'm gonna go on tour with
these guys it's going to blow their
minds I'm gonna have fun that's good for
everyone yeah if you want to hear a date
he was a big he loved TV on the radio so
on their album return to cookie mountain
which is one of their best he sang on
the song province Serena TV on the
Radian you didn't know that go back and
listen to the song province it's one of
their best songs but he's singing like
background vocals on us so [ __ ] cool
it's a great song too but he's [ __ ]
on it we just one day was like hey I'm
gonna help this bin and just like sing
some [ __ ] I feel so bad for him on right
now oh no his kids it's like getting to
know David Bowie on a personal level
yeah Twitter shut down Twitter became a
hundred percent David Bowie and also to
the point where every time someone
very beloved dies people start tweeting
about it and then in based out of the
four hundred people i followed there's
routinely three or four comics who begin
to make fun of the the group grieving I
and what I liked this time is it was so
overwhelmed by people being like David
Boies the [ __ ] it just stopped people
making jokes about like I guess I better
to say something about David Boies like
it didja stably went away it was like
nah man I get yet yeah you're right
we're all doing a thing together there's
a reason right because this guy was the
best yet they don't be in in like oh
you're are you saying he wasn't the best
or you're like oh everyone's doing it
yeah so what yeah sometimes that's what
is necessary because someone is so
universally beloved yeah and the fact
that that many people are having a
common reaction to one person and what
they did because they did it in a way
that was kind of right is fantastic and
I like it one of the big trends I saw
with the would be like a bow pouring of
like grief in love and rent and support
all that was how many people
specifically said they loved him and are
sad because he touched them in a way
that was not common back then like the
70s 80s and probably even the 90s where
he made it okay for them to be outcasts
or weird he made it like he basically
told them it's okay to be different it's
okay to like look and act if right or B
or be seen as what is now considered
different if you were like gay or bi or
trans gender or just had like a very
effeminate way of looking dressing or
acting he without even saying it he just
was doing it so you were like well if he
can do it then it's fine and that got a
lot of kids like I I was I like I appeal
not i appealed like those artists
appealed to me like guys like him and
like marilyn manson and yeah and people
that were in
dawn and Michael Jackson like there was
something and I didn't know when I was a
kid but there was something about I'm
saying with Madonna Michael Jackson's I
was like 8 10 11 i was just like there's
something so interesting about what
they're doing and yeah and i connect to
do it because it was just different I
think with people like them Madonna
Michael Jackson David Bowie their prints
they're also concerned with something
being interesting and artistic that it
doesn't matter to them where it came
comes from doesn't matter there there
aren't lines in the same way there
aren't gender lines in the same way if
something's interesting but they find it
beautiful or compelling the source is it
doesn't who gives a [ __ ] they're just
like that's what is that I want to do
that or I want to make that or I want to
look like that and where it comes from
they don't have those like preconceived
hang ups or like well if I borrow from
this people will think I'm this like no
no but that's great who cares right but
imagine I mean you and I are too young
but imagine being 15 or 16 when Ziggy
Stardust comes out yeah and you're a kid
who feels different or feels weird or
want it and doesn't fit in and you're
like oh [ __ ] but by the time you and I
were teenagers the people that were
inspired by David Bowie were we're doing
that so like you know if you like
marilyn manson huge huge hugely inspired
by David Bowie oh for sure and so a lot
of other guys that like Alice Cooper and
people like that who are the people like
that but every you all everyone at a
young age has that has that if you are a
person that wants to maybe try to be
different or unique or you feel
different there's a person that you see
first or that you meet and like well you
do it I think you're cool all do you
have tattoos you dress different you
have this hairstyle you dyed your hair
whatever it is and he was that guy on a
[ __ ] world level and one of the first
I'm sure there's someone before him that
I don't know us that maybe was this big
that he saw and that you know he he was
like you're crazy and you're doing
awesome [ __ ] I'm gonna like be inspired
by you but he was the one who was huge
and did it on a huge level and it was
just a [ __ ] massive calling card for
anyone in the world be like you wanna be
weird be weirdest [ __ ] yeah it's totally
cool and it will work be yourself go be
weird as hell yeah and it'll work only
in the sense that like on a soup unlike
in a microcosm it'll work because you
will just be able to exist as you want
yeah right it's not even it'll work
because you can be famous for doing
these weird expressive thing but you can
just like instead of having the desire
to like dress a certain way because it
just [ __ ] feels good to do yeah you
can just now do it and then feel that
sense of like I feel comfortable because
this is what I want to wear that's how I
want to have my hair or this is the way
I want to talk and that [ __ ] I want to
listen to and tell people that I like
you can just [ __ ] do it and then live
your life as opposed like keeping all
that [ __ ] bottled up yeah and then that
in and of itself is like that's a
personal victory and growing up you know
we grew up in the suburbs right so there
was not a lot of people like acting out
in that way right you had maybe two
three or four sum like that her great or
some [ __ ] um so it was never like
something you could just like walk
outside i'm [ __ ] weird now you know
but you turn on mtv or like or whatever
else back then and you see a guy or look
at an album cover in a record store and
you go oh well I mean that guy's doing
it and then you listen to their music
and you're like he's saying cool [ __ ]
he's doing it in a cool way a lot of
people are starting to like this yeah
I'm gonna [ __ ] kind of take on some
of that I'm gonna like die my hair now
I'm gonna dress a little weird and then
go dude how [ __ ] cool is David Bowie
that's why I'm dressing [ __ ] yeah he is
cool I'm gonna start wearing I'm gonna
dye my hair every four days and it's
tiny things like that we're like you
know people that have varied quote
unquote normal lives rights like you
walk by their cubicle and you notice
like she's got like sweet lightning bolt
earrings or like a little David Bowie
thing at her desk you're like like April
our friend April Richardson yeah told me
that the way she became friends with
dave grohl is cuz when she worked at
shell
see her desk was [ __ ] insane are
trying to music it was just the in the
kind of stuff in it blue posters and
things in it were you know very obscure
and like he gave girl like Cruz pastured
it was like whoa wait whoa whoa you know
the kind of [ __ ] you like oh you're into
some serious [ __ ] over here just like oh
like you know weena classic a cravat
like uh yeah word I'm definitely in
adobe [ __ ] you know it ya like like be
friends yeah here's a VHS tape you know
like it but that it's that it's those
tiny little calling cards that it ended
what's and you and I both know this is
it's it's it's done under the guise of
like I'm unique but it's basically a way
to find other people that are quote
unquote unique in the exact same way
like yo I love the same [ __ ] as you
there's just less of us let's hang out
all right but it's that thing it's that
those little things you find out
someone's like this is so dumb but you
find it like Ann Coulter loves the
Grateful Dead right you're like huh
interesting okay look you're super into
this she's like I'm super into the dead
you're like okay that's weird as hell
but if you cruise by like Ann Coulter's
desk or whatever and you saw like one of
those bears you're like i said uh
grateful never yeah it's those little
things to tell you like oh you're a
human yeah okay it tells you more about
a person than just their job or their
car or the outfit they wear at work
we're like oh no on weekends I dress up
I do the rocky horror picture thing
you're like really yeah I do the Susan
Sarandon character like oh [ __ ] cool he
once said about style style is about the
choices you make to create the aspects
of civilization that you wish to uphold
damn it David Bowie yeah so damn it
David Bowie it's a thoughtful quote
about why you would dress and act all
right you're like I care about
efficiency I care about design I care
about this and the aspects of
civilization that he wished to uphold
were apparently the unique individual
should be I mean if you just like that's
just me looking at him and his style I
go I think what you were trying to
uphold was be yourself create what you
want do what you want be who you are and
that's your focus through life and
also don't be afraid to be inspired by
things that aren't you make a soul
record because that says like hey just
you know there are people over here who
aren't like you who are making really
good [ __ ] really interesting [ __ ] that
you should know about and I'm inspired
by that it's like you know everyone kind
of will clown the the Paul Simon African
records but they're good and I didn't
know about that music till I heard that
[ __ ] it mean if I was it if I was like
blown away by the bike wheelies guys
like oh he performed with this orchestra
you look up that Orchestra like oh
they're that they're from this area they
were on this label this label made that
it's like liking everyone likes Bob
Marley but you like Bob Marley and the
Wailers you look up tuff gong or
whatever the labeling like who else is
on this label yeah and like all it it's
it all that stuff is just their little
doorways into new into other kind of
[ __ ] it's like okay I like glam rock
because I like David Bowie well who else
makes glam rock oh [ __ ] t-rex is pretty
good right so that's how you learn about
all that stuff and there's no way he
didn't know he was doing that [ __ ] and
that was so goddamn cool his hair David
Bowie never had a bad hair day and a hit
a lot of guys than once in his life a
lot of interesting here it is he this is
a rough one man it really like it's
funny because when I found out about it
was like after I left alive concert
right I myself wondering if they
announce it at your concert don't know
one I mean if it happened at ten-thirty
that concert got out of 11 right and I'm
telling you know I mean there might have
been five people but I'm sitting there
scrolling through their twitter or
something during there was an
intermission ordering like it you know
uh and maybe they saw but I doubt anyone
started announcing it to anybody and
there's no way you know and not a band
like that's gonna stop the show and make
the announce tool fans aren't phone
lookers at at during a chef yeah not
really they're more into they're just
they're [ __ ] like let's get into this
you know uh and uh yeah I mean I didn't
really even have like good service i
posted like two or three pictures but
each one took 30 minutes to upload but I
mean I just put my phone away and then
sango under the picture when I failed
yeah reupload again so this not a lot of
people had the chance even to sit there
and just [ __ ] on their phone and
stuff but I was thinking to today I was
like if if i did find out during the
show what I've turn to my friend and be
like dude guess what happened I'd have
been like probably not yeah I would have
waited until it ended or if I went like
oh my god and he was like what's wrong
no nothing no Susie which I you said oh
[ __ ] you ruin a show yeah then I would
about art will do you really want to
know all right David Bowie you know yeah
but I mean honestly I don't think he's
dead right what we're talking about him
like he's not dead this is we could have
done this episode any other we could you
do David Bowie episode any time would
have had no problem doing the episode it
would sounding basically the same right
at the sentimental thing too is that
like he isn't he is a dead because he's
the least dead dead person I think in
the world yeah i mean really he's i mean
his physical body is dead right he's
he's dead but the guy left such a
[ __ ] undeniable long lasting mark on
pop culture worldwide yeah that he's
kind of not dead that's why I feel so
bad for his family cuz he's really dead
to them well I mean yeah but to us sure
there's so much David Bowie out there
that I probably even have yet to
discover and stuff yeah that he's kind
of not dead to the Pete to his fans but
it [ __ ] sucks yeah he's I can't even
it just sounds so dumb when you talk
when you just keep saying he's deeply
look you just keep saying his name yeah
cuz the do i I just don't he's one of
the heaviest dudes ever it's incredible
and it that like it's it's so
interesting you look at him a lot of his
song like the songs were he look his
visual style is like so like kind of
like interesting and like gender neutral
he's playing like stripped down regular
rock songs yeah and but it's a like this
was groundbreaking in but it that guy
played he knew how to make a very normal
great song you know how to make a weird
song like that just find me he waits
from like just kind of like tone down
mod rock to like hard rock and were like
oh this is interesting as conceptual
and weird and then you're like yeah and
then he goes well now i'm doing soul
music and like oh I mean [ __ ] that work
too I guess you're like when he dress
sfe thing now is like well actually not
anymore cuz now i'm doing like dance
stuff I did there's this drawing in a
long time what used to be my house but
it was like a guy with like holding up
high water pants is one hundred percent
of drawing a David though right I just
cut the head off a chant did put
suspenders onyx I didn't want anyone to
know is what hundred percent a drawing
of David Bowie yeah when he's doing the
[ __ ] that was doing that thing the
like prep the super waspy thing which I
think he kind of hated but there's I was
behind the music on that tour which I
forget what was the huge changes might
have been a huge hit from that tour yeah
but like one of his friends like what he
doing he just went there's a there's a
quote in here were one of his albums
station to station I think it's station
to station were yeah he apparently was
doing so much drugs he says I don't
remember making that record i remember
it was in LA because i read it was in LA
I made it it was not so much I mean that
was the seventies and there's there's a
lot of that bad day I mean Neil Young I
think had a couple of those where he was
like I was like really [ __ ] up and
yeah sick I didn't he like in a fever
dream sort of like state wrote down by
the river yeah like barely remembers one
of Oasis records they'd said they's like
he goes uh yeah this one record we were
so coked up it's terrible but we still
sold six million copies all right yeah
yeah it's it's [ __ ] I mean they don't
make them like that anymore it's hard
it's hard to see a maybe this is just
like us as old dudes being like that's
the thing though we're not all I know
but this is what what your old people
say but maybe maybe the the the way
music is right now is so open that maybe
it's the a really good situation to make
someone like that because you can do so
many different things it's so much
easier to make music but I was thinking
about that too is because he didn't come
up in a time when it was really easy to
make music digitally and there wasn't
pro tools and things like that
synthesizers exist but they wouldn't
brought he still had to learn how to
make
good songs and he still had that I think
that mechanism of musicians having to
learn how to make music on musical
instruments tied you to music history
more because the way you learn as you
play old music yeah be he he's also he
was in actual musician like he from when
he was a kid he was like he learned
instruments yeah you had a plan but yeah
you had to like I mean more than just
like learning about like the history
whatever you used real musicians so if
you were like gonna have a backing band
it was gonna be people from all walks of
life you had you know white people from
Detroit black people from Philadelphia
[ __ ] yeah so and so from whatever
other parts of the country who were
trained and knew the history so you
brought all those people into one room
like you could just pull [ __ ] up on a
computer or hit buttons on like you know
yeah or a rig yeah you had to bring in
if you you're like I want a chorus on
you know young Americans or whatever you
to bring five or six people in to the
studio yeah and then you had to have all
your instrumentalists all in there all
in one room for however many you know
days or weeks it took to record these
yeah so like you were tethered to and
those people created influences and they
had a say and they range what was
happening and now because it's all you
can do it so by yourself you can just
sit in a [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment
and just go I'm making an album yeah and
I wonder if that I think I think you get
two things from that you can be a the
most creative person possible because or
and ever because you have access to
literally everything right but it also
can lead to I don't know just like super
simple garb homogenized garbage it's the
kind of thing we're like I wonder I
would love to see someone like Gary
Clark jr. get hyper weird because he's
so well versed in traditional music
making go to rock music making in blues
and things like that it's like if he if
you were like here here's a computer
Gary you can only use this it's like
dude i'd be willing to listen to what
that was like I mean I don't even know
if you know what to do with it that's
what's so interesting it's like that I
mean that's why Bowie was working with
someone like Brian Eno was like you're
doing weird [ __ ] over there well like
whistle with these machines
you know like is is it was that kind of
like newness that led to I think some of
the stuff he did right and I a mean
you'd hope that there are people that
hopefully are smart enough and and and
and interested enough in music to learn
both things I mean I think that's had a
really positive effect on like EDM
because that's taken it in so many
different directions because you just
you're sitting there on a computer like
putting sounds together and you need so
many sounds it has to be nonstop yeah
and but for like four instrument driven
like music you know like groups and
bands and stuff like I don't know what
it's I mean if it's gonna create more
artists like this or I wonder cuz I want
now we see there's there's like music is
pretty broken up in all these little
areas but you see like neo-soul you know
the Alabama Shakes or all the broken
bone yeah st. Paul the broken bones so
it's like well what's the the generation
of kids who like that and want to be in
a band but don't necessarily want to
sound like those people cuz they want to
stand out what are they going to do they
can combine that with something else
what to do that they got to learn they
gotta learn how to play for real and
then what do they combine it with so
hopefully it's those mixes that turn
into stuff that's the that's the thing
that's like taking away from all that
originality is that everything is so
subdivided yet people like we're gonna
do we're gonna bring back soul we're
gonna do yeah bring back blues or we're
gonna bring back than 80s or 90s or
whatever and then you just get people
that are just copying something else for
your most part not yet be really well
done like st. Paul the broken bones now
the shakes a really talented people they
make good music but I mean are we gonna
look back at Alabama Shakes in the same
way we look back on like David Bowie and
prints and Neil Young and yeah and and
all these other artists we don't think
so i think the Alabama Shakes second
record is kind of it's very different
from the first record but yeah you want
to see them be like okay you guys are
really good [ __ ] break out yeah do
something where you're like oh whoa
yet one records people hate yeah
something super we have a retail dark
divide be like this is a [ __ ] love
hate thing and because most money comes
from Turing I'd go see if the Alabama
Shakes released a record now that I hate
it I'd still go see him because there's
going to be two albums where the songs
that I really like and they do big shows
like they're not an easy man to get
tickets cuz they're know people know
they're really good life you know who's
who's starting to do that kind of thing
right now and only time will tell where
where it goes is tame impala okay I
don't know that is so they he mostly
it's one guy but he plays with a band
but he does like he's one of those dudes
that like I ride all the music you know
and then we play it live so they're kind
of like a psychedelic rock outfit right
huh so and they're really good so they
had a an album that kind of started
getting them attention called inner
speaker and they put an album two years
ago Cal owner ISM and it is [ __ ] on
the money dude it's like really cool 7ds
ish like psychedelic rock it's [ __ ]
great there's so many this on
wall-to-wall great album then he puts
out an album this year are 2015 called
currents and P the buzz was already out
like it's a departure from what they're
doing he just went in a totally
different direction it's like more
electronica but still rock the opening
tracks like eight minutes long and
you're like what and but so a part of
you feel you like but lonerism was so
good and this is what you're doing and I
want like more of that but then you're
like just have a little faith in this
guy like yeah he's good he's talented
he's taking a risk maybe it'll [ __ ]
pay off and if it doesn't maybe they'll
go back and do what they were doing and
have learned from this departure and add
a little bit of that to the next one
careers are long artists take risks they
try it's not just one one album for one
album yeah let the dude do his thing so
he's very good he's very talented the
band's great he put out currents and it
was one of the best albums of the year
last year it's a [ __ ] awesome yeah
but the things he was doing in it you're
like the combination of like genres and
sounds you listen to whole
your septic for music genres in here
yeah and I mean I'm the nice thing about
being older is you uh when I when if I
like abandoned and I get and I hear they
did a really weird album I'm like all
right yeah it gives me faith in like oh
I get to like you for a long time and
that's the one thing that should I think
be taken away from like the current
state of music is that you can do
whatever you want yeah so if you are
sitting there like all right we put out
two albums that are like hard rock hits
but we want to you know do another one
where we like introduce a little bit of
electronic or a country or fall or
whatever or a mash of all of it and we
don't know how it's gonna sound I mean
the cost the risk is all very low now
yeah just [ __ ] put it out yeah it's
not like MTV's gonna stop playing your
[ __ ] they're not playing anybody [ __ ]
yeah we word about the radio no one's on
the red no one gets their music from the
radio yeah right the album record it put
it on Spotify see what happens yeah and
then move on you can do that in comedy
now yeah you can just do whatever you
want yeah and you go I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna make a series of videos and
put on YouTube I'm gonna record an album
and put it online no one can tell you
not to yeah and then time will tell
whether what you did is good or bad or
just a stepping stone to the great thing
you did three years later or so on and
so forth but like now's the time for
like people like this to become the next
you know Bowie or prince or whatever
because it's the tools are at your
disposal and everything's free that's
what I was thinking I wanted to like
there's any like thing people should do
because of the death of David Bowie's
like emulate that dude yeah like let's
see where it takes you for real everyone
go out and try to be a little more like
David Bowie I treated that today I was
like today should be national address
weird he should have a holiday yeah I
bet they should have one in England for
sure yeah but yeah just go like try to
be like that dude he did it right yeah
go do something that you normally would
be like yeah I get what I get looks for
that or people would make fun of me and
then do that thing I'm
King in his ashes to ashes video he
dressed as a mime right guys do you
realize the bravery it takes two dresses
a mine yeah how many of you dressed like
a mime ever in your life yeah not
counting Halloween and made it work do
you understand how hard that is yeah
[ __ ] modern love that's a banger
that's the hit when he was like super
preppy look yeah that was a big one
great hair i untied bowtie on [ __ ] I
think I think man who sold the world I
think was the album cover where he was
just wearing a woman's dress really yeah
I'm pretty sure that's it yeah that dude
yeah I'm pretty sure that's it and that
was his third album not a lot of people
and he was just like i'm gonna wear a
dress that was like ebony whatever 1970
yeah uh yeah it's did I mean I don't
know him there's not a lot you don't get
a lot of people like that that passed
through the world and like leave that
kind of mark on any society you know no
so is he's he conquered the whole world
and did it for a long time and did it
right and it was [ __ ] he's Bowie man
that's why when that guy when Alan the
writer of this book said that because
you gotta understand all anyone wanted
to be was Bowie yeah that punks who were
all about just like [ __ ] everything
everything sucks but not Bowie is like
no no we're just trying to be Bowie man
this guy's the [ __ ] I always had a
repulsive need to be something more than
human oh man I hope they're I hope I
mean I hope after you know I hope I hope
Iman talks about him i want i would love
to see like a long interviews like tell
us about that guy because he's I mean
the mystery around like I don't know a
lot about him personally or I just
usually gay he's the best thing ever
like I want to know what that dude was
sort of like I'd love to hear his kids
talk about him like this is what he was
like at home I'm the opposite I think
you don't want anything I think
everything we need is out there yeah I
mean that's true for sure yeah you don't
need he gave us plenty right again I
mean I've looked up kind of watches the
guy wore that's all pictures like what's
that one I don't reckon it looks like
that yeah so looked it up i priced them
very reasonable very welcome you didn't
wear an outlandish watch very normal
yeah yeah I think we have everything we
already need you know like the the
getting in I mean there's a reason he
kept his personal life personal he was
smart because it he was our he was
giving you everything that he wanted to
give you and you took it and then we've
carried that impression of him along
which is which is all that is if you're
an artist you're giving out your
impression of you in the world and then
the the the fans and whoever take that
and they go great that's David Bowie but
when people start digging in all the
other [ __ ] it's like it it'll change it
pollutes it yeah it changes your
perception it's like wool so what if he
[ __ ] you know didn't care about the
environment enough and you're and you
really do you're gonna like the guy less
now yeah he was not caring about the
environment when he [ __ ] wrote
hunky-dory yeah so there's no difference
yeah but then it'll like plant that
[ __ ] seat in your head where he you
know did one or two things that you
don't agree with ya and which you know
for the most part with artists or minor
little things but you go all I thought
he was cooler than that it's like no you
didn't you don't know anything about him
yeah you know his albums you know his
movies you know this you know that and
it's all you should be left with but man
that guy it sounds it's it's if he's so
great you sound silly saying he's great
because it's just about the most obvious
thing in the world yeah it's like saying
water is wet but David Bowie he's David
Bowie was just so David Bowie yeah he's
saying his name about it Bowie like he's
the David Bowie of being David Bowie
yeah man there's not they don't make
them like that anymore I wish they did a
lot of people trying to pretend they're
gonna media who is who's gonna be the
next like dude I don't know is that we
don't have one now I'll tell you that I
don't think they're I think they're
under the age of 21 if they exist at all
probably
way they're gonna come from a place we
had no idea they're gonna come for I
hope so I don't think it's America yeah
I mean usually isn't I think it's I
think it's somebody's gonna gonna gonna
take a bunch of [ __ ] and combined in a
way we're all gonna be like whoa yeah
and they're gonna do it in a way that's
so mind-blowing yeah we I mean they're
you know a healthy like society of any
kind needs people like this you know you
need to have artists that are doing
things like this that like [ __ ] unify
bring people together and go we can
enjoy this this is an expression of you
know who we are but who the who diz
there isn't that now I mean with the big
stars now are like justin timberlake and
katy perry and lady gaga and in a Taylor
Swift and people like that who are like
fine they have talent they can play
instruments and they make good pop songs
but like I don't know that I guess the
closest would be Taylor Swift like she's
making a mark and she's touching people
because she writes her music and like
you know well thought out and all that
stuff and but the rest of them are you
know they came out of a [ __ ]
laboratory but even with a Taylor Swift
it's like where's the weird bravery and
maybe that's not her taste no she's a
pop star but she has the power to do it
he sure go along with her yet there's no
unique weird sort of like oh that's
coming from the depths of your [ __ ]
twisted soul there's Anna that bit and
she's she's not that type of artisan you
can't knock her for just not having that
in her you know she does what she does
very well I guess you could say Kanye
Kanye is yeah he's creative dude he's
creative and weird and there's a lot of
love hate yeah forum his musics good
yeah Kanye pushes it we are I think it'd
be we can't like not mention that dude
yeah he's like very heavily and again
what you know world what you said about
personal life his personal life ruins a
lot of [ __ ] for me his personal life is
yeah it's way too out there but that
that is the difference between then and
now yeah I think then there was you know
there was obviously no gossip magazines
of TMZ no internet so people could just
[ __ ] I want to know this so we're
gonna dig and find out and then it's
everywhere people just chose what they
put out there
you know but now it's like your insides
are your outsides yeah you know they're
they're all over the plate what do you
like it or not yeah you marry some like
Kim Kardashian it's like you know good
luck having a private life in any way
anymore yeah but I mean maybe that's a
part of who he is as an artist or he's
like there is no yeah there's no Ingrid
there's no naivete he didn't like meet
her when she was unfamous like he went
for that thing it was a part there was
something about that that appealed to
him so whatever who knows what knows
what that was yeah but now dude this is
a rough one it is man it is i woke up it
was the first thing i thought of when I
woke up I opened my eyes and I was like
[ __ ] David Bowie's gone the whole
drive home from San Diego last night I
just listened to Bowie the entire way
and I woke up and all morning was just
like was just bowing yeah so my
suggestion to you guys listening go out
get all the boys music you can get your
hands on yeah go get a [ __ ] sweet
Bowie t-shirt draw a lightning bolt on
your face to put a lightning bolt on
your cat do what ever get a tattoo yeah
go go get your weird on man yeah go get
a little mini mini lightning lightning
bolt somewhere by the way if you want a
pin if you think there aren't plenty of
David Bowie pins out there and if you
think in the next three weeks aren't
going to be 50 20 or we're about to be
in a David Bowie enamel pin Renaissance
so ready yourself you're gonna see Homer
Simpson with the lightning bolt on space
you're gonna see a lot of that so if
that's gonna be your thing get ready
your bank accounts ready or paypal
because it's about to get busy out there
right yeah uh and I mean if you're not
if you haven't gotten into the music in
any way it's all obviously online itunes
apple music spotify try to go in order I
think that'll be a more rewarding thing
that's a good way to do it with him
because you get to see the evolution of
an abbess pretty much but like uh
because there's hits along the way
you're gonna get a hit every you know
yeah every album has you know one maybe
two already heard like but what's what I
mean what's good about him is like a lot
of his albums were concept out yeah like
you can there's a lot of best of Bowie's
stuff so I guess you could do that and
like
here oh yeah these r is it you'll come
across a couple your book those but you
know but listen to the [ __ ] whole
albums because you get an idea of what
this guy was doing like way back then
you know you listen to like Ziggy
Stardust and like diamond dogs and and
Space Oddity and stuff like they were it
wasn't just a collection of songs they
were like conceptual pieces of work yeah
everyone knows space oddity but it's
like what was the song he wrote to go
with it what is the song he thought was
a good idea to put after on the record
that shit's interesting yeah I mean
there's a lot of like uh there's a lot
of stuff on there where you could go
like signet committee is a great song on
that album God knows I'm good is a
really good one but those are sensible
you're like I think I've heard this but
you're like yeah that's a [ __ ] Bowie
song and that was on an album where you
only ever really heard that one spit the
actual song Space Oddity on on the radio
and stuff yeah um and hunky dorys a good
one like his first like five albums or
something like that five or six even and
then he gets a little more experimental
and different he goes into like dance
stuff in the 80s and stuff after like
heroes and all that [ __ ] rock heroes
Jesus yeah I like the a83 or something
let's dance came out and then he rose is
a huge hit you've heard a million times
and you could hear a million more times
and it does not bother you in any way
yeah never turned that song awful yeah I
mean and that was like just one of the
ones on the [ __ ] album yeah um but
yeah so there's a lot out there i mean
but i would start from the very first
one and go into the mid-80s he was in a
couple bands before he was David Bowie
to ya when he was AI when he was way
younger put out some stuff um look up
that clip of him defending men with the
long hair it's funny yeah there's a lot
is a lot out there now I mean you should
[ __ ] type it into Twitter search bar
at Google and there's just like a
thousand articles coming out and you
could have a channel you could have a
David Bowie channel on television it
could easily yeah that's another another
hero yep gone heroes a good thing to
call them dudes a hero the legend
well that's it um I hope this wasn't too
much of a bummer episode but it's on
everyone's [ __ ] mind is definitely on
ours so we were going to do something
we're gonna pretend and not we were
doing something different that if in red
like it would have been hard to get you
know without bringing a real stupid to
do it we would have gone on like a side
track and it woulda turned into an
episode about David Bowie anyway but you
know what you don't get a lot of these
guys in life so when you do and they're
gone you talk about him you pay respects
in whatever way you want anyway I'm
gonna go listen to David Bowie for the
rest of the day do the same